talk about our boy rogan hmm
going at a going out with sanjay you
gotta call him columbus the way he's
taking out indians
the way the way to
embodied sanjay gupta dude i'm
disappointed
you say his name correctly
yeah sanjay i hate that he says sanjay i
know octopus hates this stuff it's not
hard to say sanjay and guys don't like
it when indians pronounce their name
white
on purpose for the like for no reason
for white people i like when they do
that because they recognize where the
[ __ ] they are
you should pronounce your name
based on the country that you decide to
live in so like when i was in spain i
would i would say my name is andrew and
then i would just go andrew
so that they would understand it yeah
you could just say andrew because they
don't know how to but if they called you
andrew would you be like actually it's
andrew no let's go that's fine that's
just that's the best that you could do
if you tongue doesn't work the way my
tongue works if you said andrew and they
said andrew i wouldn't correct i don't
it's up to you how you say your name
yeah yeah so for him and sanjay is not
andrew it's they you guys can say
something i wasn't choosing to spend my
life in spain yeah but you can say
like a year you see the difference
though i'm they can't say andrew you
said it americans can all say sanjay
it's an easy name say it try to say it
sanjay
[Laughter]
sanjay i have respect for you you said
i'm gonna put out j you put a d in there
no but for real dude i do feel strongly
about that like your name is pronounced
based on the country you decide to live
in but again don't bring your other [ __ ]
here and then make me feel [ __ ] up
again i fee i gotta be racist because i
can't pronounce your [ __ ] from not where
i'm from again sanjay sunday let's do it
the best what's your name phil yeah yeah
that's all i'll talk about asian just
pick a white ass name perfect we had
that exchange student drew young kim
what's your name carl carl yeah love it
can't even pronounce his own name
[Laughter]
love it
and you say young that's the girl's name
in rush hour almost yeah
oh soo young soo young oh yeah
[Laughter]
i think they want to change it up though
i think it's fun you come over you get a
new name new identity yeah it's fun you
get to live into live up to it it's
great i'm just saying you your parents
are really smart you told me how you
they picked your name this was really
smart they went to white people and they
gave a list of indian names i said which
one can you pronounce the easiest oh
really so they so they basically found a
way around the system and it was like
hey this is we want to name our kid an
indian name but also an indian name
that's easily pronounced in america by
american people yeah brilliant maintain
your culture but also respect the fact
that the majority of people speaking to
your son are not gonna know how to
pronounce it in a perfect way yeah we
still don't say it right we still don't
oshkosh my mom calls about it
i don't correct people who don't say my
name correctly because it's it's not i
don't care how you say my name i care
how i say my name
that's my identity how i carry my
identities important yeah and i even
like on a day-to-day interaction i
stopped doing this but i see my indian
friends will say it in a way like on
video one-on-one but to publicly you
wouldn't publicly go on stage and be
like hey thank you guys so much i'm
andrew if i chose to live in spain and
live there for the rest of my life
i would make that entire country bend
the knee
there you go it's andrew yeah yeah it's
and that's my issue
don't you don't got a public go on
newscast and be like hi i'm sanjay gupta
you're saying and it's so easy is it
wrong that i've said in my life when
people have pronounced their name like
super
with their accent no and then i've
pronounced it with an american accent
they've corrected me they're like that's
not how i pronounce my name and i've
said to them it is here is that yes i
don't care i don't think that's racist i
don't think that's racist if you say oh
that's how i pronounce it that's how it
is pronounced yeah it is pronounced here
like that it is pronounced like that
here in this case in god's country
that's it and we're in the country god
chose yeah we will win because god is on
our side yeah i don't need to correct
anybody
i don't need to correct anybody
mispronounces my name unless they're
indian if they're indian you know better
go ahead if you're new to the culture
you don't got to be great at it i don't
got to correct you
i just need to know i carry it properly
how do you pronounce his last name gupta
it's gupt gupta gupta
gupta yeah i say gupta i think we did
when i was younger i had a teacher miss
gupta but gupta is pretty close yeah and
it's not that's harder but sanjay i know
it's so easy for one now did rogan and
sanjay talk about anything besides
pronunciation of names i don't think
that's all they're talking about
for three hours is all i heard
okay no uh so sanjay is the medical
expert at cnn yeah okay
and he went on joe rogan's podcast yeah
right um and i'm sure all the cnn lovers
over there
make fun of rogan they call him the what
is those dumbbell things that he loves
what are those called on it
the kettlebell yeah the kettlebell bro
meathead guy etc
and sanjay goes on the kettlebell bro
meathead guys podcast the guy who
doesn't know anything oh what an idiot
this guy is just in the gym working out
that's all he cares about uh and rogan
absolutely lobotomizes this man
yeah yeah because
not because sanjay
is stupid no not because he's
unknowledgeable but because he is
working for a fraudulent organization
right that lies on purpose right and
he and this is a choice he chooses to
work there and he chooses to continue to
propagate those lies is that the right
word i'm using
um and defend those lies but when you're
faced with truth and you're a liar
there's nothing you can do yeah except
be snarky he was a snarky little [ __ ]
it was a little bit it was a little more
so i saw an interview with him talking
to cnn afterwards i want to talk about
that i want to talk about that after
getting because i want to talk the
reaction but yeah so basically joe calls
him out and calls cnn out yeah he goes
how do you feel about the fact that your
organization lied about me taking horse
dewormer yeah like they called it horsty
warmer yeah anderson cooper
um brian selter he addressed that they
put the filter on the scene yeah yeah
filtered his face to make him look more
yellow and they said and he basically
was like listen this is a drug drug that
is prescribed to billions of people
billions seems like a lot but a lot of
[ __ ] billions there's only billions
of people on the planet prescribed i've
never had yeah i don't think they're
prescribing drugs in the [ __ ]
area of china they just put on a
slingshot just shoot it out there yeah
[Laughter]
so so
still a lot of people this is a drug for
humans he was prescribed a drug by a
doctor along with a bunch of other drugs
they specifically targeted that one they
called it horse dewormer um they lied
about what he was taking and they lied
about him in general yes and he calls
out sanjay and sanjo's like well i guess
it wasn't a flattering description no
yeah yeah he tried to maneuver around it
slickly yeah and rogan
kept hammering no [ __ ] you guys
lied about me yeah and you lied about
what i was taking and then lying about
what i was taking you could have said
all the whole cocktail the stuff i was
taking and maybe people could have it
could have helped people yeah who knows
and and i think rogan was open he was
like listen there's not enough data to
show that this is actually helpful i
took a bunch of different things it
could have been the mono mono something
whatever mono
nuclear antibodies no monsters not
monoliths like monochloride or something
or something like that monoclonic
antibodies
he goes it could have been that right
it could have been a bunch of other
things that he was taking but obviously
it helped him and he survived right
and he felt like for one day he felt
sick for one day and then five days
later it was gone testing negative [ __ ]
i had that [ __ ] for way more than that
when we were doing netflix oh y'all had
that [ __ ] for 10 days too probably yeah
right
so
it was it was just really cool to see
him call out the expert from the channel
that's lying about him and see him kind
of melt under the pressure the thing is
like if if sanjay was off air i feel
like the conversation would be so
different okay like i don't know like i
feel like he's a neurosurgeon he's a
smart guy like i think that he has this
allegiance to cnn where he has to sort
of play by their you know constitution
and say and like support the
organization that if off fair he'd be
like yeah no they were trying to [ __ ]
you over like they were trying to do
this i don't think he would say we lie i
don't think i bet you he doesn't see
himself in that they lie yeah yeah he's
like i'm just the doctor they bring me
in i say the thing and then that's it
yeah but that is tough when you're under
contract they and it is tough for
another contract and then there's a
writer named barry weiss and she's been
on rogan and she used to be a new york
times writer i shouldn't think she left
the times there might have been some
scandal or she didn't want to continue
supporting them or something like that
but um and she was on brian selter's
show on cnn and recently she was calling
out she's like she's basically calling
out like what's going on here like when
you can't like it is madness when you
can't say there's a difference between
men and women it is madness when you
can't say and all these different things
matters and then or when they won't
allow you that was the term and then
brian selter was like who is they like
who won't allow you who's saying that
you can't do these things i mean you're
discussing it right now and then she
goes she goes listen brian you and i
both know because we've worked for these
organizations and you work for one right
now
that there's a culture at the
organization which rewards certain
behavior you want to have more time on
tv you want to get more articles
published you have these opinions and
those stories are going to get published
as long as they fit the opinions of the
network or the periodical the newspaper
etc so it's like
he's going yeah there is no day he goes
yeah they don't have to be explicit
about it do you want to succeed here at
the company it's almost like i'm sure
it's the same as if you're like a cop or
if you're working at the uh at the
courts or whatever it's like there's a
way where you continue to rise up in the
organization and there's a way where you
don't yeah you call out the officers you
call out bad behavior you're calling out
things that the people that make the
shield look bad
guess who's not getting a promotion yeah
and it's never written it's never a
constitution it's never like yo do these
things you'll get here it's just always
vibe energy what are you saying like
positive feedback too right unwritten
rules it's it's like it's amazing it's
almost self-policing you see someone
else getting on and you're like how the
[ __ ] he got a oh
he's kissing a ring he's playing the
rules he's doing this i guess i should
do more than it's kind of genius it's
almost how like you know that the mafia
don
never has to
uh give the instructions to the lowest
level guy who's gonna make the hit right
you know i mean it's like it's kind of
like known oh that guy was talking [ __ ]
or that guy may have hit us we know how
we get back like there's separation yeah
you know it makes sense like little
stuff like oh yeah he'll get taken care
of or something like that like just say
something casually and he's like you
know what that means like everybody
falls in line and they know what that
means and when the big boss comes out
and like praises an article a report
that was done all the other people go
well i'd like the big boss and yeah
praise
me if i wrote a piece just like that
yeah it's like what um [ __ ] nicki
minaj likes tweets that her and now her
fans go oh that's what she wants us to
talk about that's what she wants us to
do that's what she wants us to cancel
exactly so like you're pushing the
company in the direction you want
through reward and pushing it away from
the direction you do not want with not
necessarily punishment but like lack of
reward lack reward and just ignoring
but you now you were saying you saw
sanjay on cnn because i think what's
happening right now is like cnn and a
lot of these different places are
looking for their boogeyman yeah right
now that trump is gone you can't just
say trump is bad yeah so they've almost
replaced it with rogan but the problem
is that the people love rogan more than
they love cnn yes yeah right so they
don't have the animosity like even like
the most super liberal guy
has listened to a rogan interview and
been like oh i was actually really cool
he talked to like my favorite musician
and he seemed like a pretty interesting
guy like yeah
and also he's not saying things that are
as salacious as trump yeah like trump
was just out there with women rogan's
vaccine take is very centered just like
look i just
i didn't fully agree with him where he
was like i want uh i don't i think you
only need it if you're like fat or older
i believe in that i i think i think if
you're an adult you can take it but i
completely agree with what his main
gripe is which is i don't think we
should give it to kids so that's what he
said to me he was like bro once you have
kids this whole [ __ ] changes like and i
agree i'm with him on that i think
adults can get it kids i don't want to i
don't want to shoot them up yet yeah and
if they give it to an adult who is
vaccinated he'll get a little sick okay
big deal yeah yeah yeah that's like
that's the flu okay like if you're if
you're like a scientist you're actually
going by the numbers like
apparently having the antibodies is more
effective than the vaccine which he also
brought up to sanjay and sunday was like
you're right mm-hmm and that was like
why do why does he need the vets now
that he got the edge and this is where
cnn is also so i saw a reaction piece
right
and one piece they played that part and
it's fine then sunday starts off
relatively centered then they play this
part where joe goes the best immunity is
to get the vaccine and then get it
really and then sanjay in the interview
is like what what do you mean he's like
what you get the vaccine you have
immunity and then you get kovid so you
still you only get a little bit sick but
now you have the super strong antibodies
from getting sick which is again it
makes a ton of sense and then sanjay
made it like he flipped it like he's
like i don't think anybody should
intentionally want to get the
vaccinations
they're terrified of saying the wrong
thing that could be misinterpreted and
blah blah blah but he also was just like
uh they were like i'm sorry
i also understand that a little bit
because like as a doctor you have a
different responsibility as like a
podcast exactly or as a comedian that's
fair as a doctor you can't and if you
were like america's doctor which they
position him as yeah you really can't be
out there like yo get vaccinated get it
yeah and start making out with
[ __ ] at a concert because then
you're gonna have the antibodies because
people will do that yes yeah so
they said something i don't remember his
exact response but i remember one of the
cuck anchors was like well you're a lot
more patient than i am sanjay i don't
know that i could have sat there for
three hours and listened to that and
then sanji was like this little one yeah
and then sanji was like yeah you know
your head is different you're definitely
spinning a lot of different directions
it's it's hard to get you know to know
what's going on or something kind of
smug like that and it's like bruh
you were on there and you were saying
you were playing ball with rogan now you
get off and all of a sudden yeah i don't
know i don't know what i was in that was
a crazy place yeah like we're in a
[ __ ] narnia i did give him i'd like
give him props for going on in the first
place and like putting himself in that
position and like having a conversation
but i was annoyed when he went on with
don lemon specifically because don lemon
was like well rogan suggested that we
lied uh we never actually lied
ivermectin is a horse dewormer so it was
never a lie and it's like and that's
sanjay's uh sanjay right there can go
yeah but we could have said he took
ivermectin and we said he took it but
rogan doesn't pay his bills so he's like
that's true
i know where my bread's buttered i'm i'm
with you guys exactly that is the thing
it's like technically speaking they
didn't lie yeah technically some
legalese like attorney [ __ ] yes
is ivermectin
used for horses and 100 percent before
they ran that headline they had the
lawyers look at it
yeah 100 percent you get this 100 now i
would argue they did lie
with making him look yellow
yeah
that's a lie yeah you're making him look
unhealthy yeah on purpose i mean we all
agree yeah it's a lie but like i think
in the legal definition the fcc all that
[ __ ] yeah they could go hey listen we're
just filtered we filter pictures all the
time we want to make sure we did have
the best quality on the tv at home we
had to make it reach whatever standards
but they did give out misleading
information yeah it's intentionally
manipulating the truth yes and when
you're a news organization you should be
held to a higher standard for misleading
information yeah if you're [ __ ]
entertainment tonight
and you want to put out rogue tmz yeah
it's like i don't even care [ __ ]
mustache on him who cares like it
doesn't matter at all but when you're
the news yeah the literal news yeah and
the chiron is
rogan takes horse
what is it dewormer
yeah
yeah
it's it feels like a like a character
assassination even though they probably
didn't break any any laws also
is it every drug
a horse drug when you just take more of
it
[Laughter]
like if a horse's knee hurts and you
give it mad ass you got a horse heart
surgery yeah where they do surgery on
the horse no you got horse hearts like
every drug like ketamine pepto-bismol
they give benadryl to dogs if i'm taking
benadryl in my teeth you took dog
allergy medicine you took all you take
dog dog medicine you take dog i do i
guess hey man i don't think the medicine
for animals specifically mammals is that
different and i'm no [ __ ] vet but i
doubt it's that different because when
you're a vet you just get to be a vet
for all the animals you don't even got
to specialize it's not like you're a
hippopotamus vet yeah like literally we
treat all animals like all right you
know them all yeah you didn't spend time
learning
archaeologists yeah you are a vet you do
all animals all parts because we don't
even care if that [ __ ] hurts them that
bad we don't know if your really deworms
mad horse is reading this article like
fam that [ __ ] don't even work on this
i got worms every single day don't know
what the side effects come on y'all
[ __ ] it's crazy i don't even like
carrots no more galloping
but yeah i mean we're [ __ ] up with
horses they break their leg we just
shoot them in the head it's crazy yeah
that's crazy yeah we shouldn't be going
to horses for medical advice in general
bro
how do you even call yourself a vet when
you break the leg you know how crazy a
horse might feel in that moment like the
leg is broken you see the the [ __ ]
gun getting put together
why are you doing it
first you're like oh thank god the
doctor's here yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're gonna fix it hey are they okay
they're on the knee they want my knee
hurt i don't speak english so it's hard
for them to understand you got the knee
okay what's that guy doing hey hey why
is it hey what are you doing
it's not my head not my head at all
veterinarians you're not doctors y'all
i'm sorry
every time i go to the vet i'm like yo
my doctor got diarrhea they're like all
right just wait a few days all right
thank you doctor of dogs
isn't that crazy yeah i've gotten better
dog advice from your sister
who's not i mean she she trains and
breathes she's not a classically trained
vet though but she's not but she she'll
be like she'll give me like the old like
wives tale medicine yeah she'll give me
like mexican like like uh you know what
i
mean
she give me like brazilian favela fennel
seed under their nose bro
rub a tomato on their chest
the tomatoes gonna suck out all the
demons yeah go beast one time
[Laughter]
all i'm saying is it's it is crazy and i
think you can be able to call most
medicines that are commonly used like
for example like when someone takes 20
ad bills and and just tries to kill
themselves as suicide
do you say
guy took one
horse dose
dose of advil
to kill himself
guy od is on horse head uh headache
medicine
right you're lying yeah you're not but
you are i mean you saw the thing that
rogan posted where he's like i've been
drinking lots of water and then the cnn
headline is joe rogan for most ingesting
liquid commonly used as engine coolant
yeah and it's like all right yeah you
can you can twist anything and flip it
and sound crazy yeah if you want to go
with someone's character yeah it's
technically not illegal oh and and just
to point out and mark was saying this
even when we took a break like fox does
the exact same [ __ ] 100 percent they all
do the exact same [ __ ] thing here's
the thing we expected it a fox and maybe
because we're like liberal [ __ ] so we
grew up in liberal conferences you grew
up in new york you're like yeah fox
garbage yeah we just grew up thinking
everything that fox puts out is bias and
fake yeah we thought that cnn was just
truthful and now that we found out that
cnn and fox are literal mirror images of
one another
they're both
you